à grande échelle.
Cela débute souvent avec des croquis.
Je dessinais ce portrait rotatif de 18 mètres
de l'artiste en qualité diffusion,
puis je déchirais la feuille de papier en deux.
Je changeais le masque
afin d'accéder à l'humain en dessous.
Dessiner les croquis est une chose, mais le traduire
en un bâtiment rotatif accessible de six étages
demandait des ingénieurs exceptionnels travaillant nuit et jour pendant 3 mois,
jusqu'à finalement arriver à Miami
pour débuter le concert en avril 2016.
(Vidéo : Applaudissements)
(Musique : « Formation », Beyoncé)
Beyoncé : Vous, les ringards qui me détestez, et dites que je suis Illuminati
Les paparazzi, mitraillez bien mon style insolent, ma beauté présomptueuse
Si téméraire et dangereuse quand je m'affiche dans ma robe Givenchy
Si possessive que j'arbore ses chaînes Roc
Un 'pa d'Alabama
Une 'man de Louisiane
Tu mélanges ce Nègre avec cette Créole
et t'obtiens une plouc texane
(La musique s'arrête)
J'appelle mon travail –
(Applaudissements)
Merci.
(Acclamations, applaudissements)
J'appelle mon travail la sculpture scénique,
mais bien sûr, ce qui est sculpté, c'est le ressenti du public.
En tant que metteurs en scène et designers,
nous avons la responsabilité
de chaque minute que le public passe avec nous.
Nous sommes un peu comme des pilotes de ligne
guidant 100 000 passagers sur une route aérienne.
Pour l'artiste canadien The Weeknd,
nous avons traduit l'esprit de cette route aérienne
à travers un origami pliable d'avion en papier
qui décolle au-dessus des gens dans le public,
pour se désagréger au milieu du vol
et ressortir ensuite rétabli des cendres,
à la fin du concert.
Comme pour chaque vol,
la partie la plus délicate est le décollage, le début,
car quand vous concevez un concert pop,
la matière première sur laquelle vous travaillez
ne doit pas fournir beaucoup d'efforts à transporter.
Cela ne coûte rien,
pourtant, avant le début du concert, chaque atome d'air en est rempli.
C'est ce qu'attend le public.
Chacun amène avec soi l'histoire de ce qui l'a mené jusqu'ici,
les distances qu'il a parcourues,
les mois de travail pour payer le billet.
Parfois, ils passent la nuit dehors près du stade
et notre mission première est d'offrir au public ce qu'il attend,
un premier contact mémorable avec l'artiste.
Quand je travaille avec des hommes,
ils sont heureux de voir leur musique transformée en métaphore –
des vaisseaux spatiaux, des montagnes.
Avec les femmes, nous travaillons plus sur des masques et des portraits 3D,
car les admirateurs d'une artiste féminine
désirent voir son visage.
Quand le public est venu voir le premier concert live d'Adele en cinq ans,
ils ont été reçus par cette image d'elle les yeux fermés.
S'ils y ont prêté attention,
ils ont entendu sa respiration en train de dormir, se diffusant dans le stade,
attendant de se réveiller.
Voici comment le concert a démarré.
(Vidéo : Acclamations, applaudissements)
(Musique)
Adele : Bonjour.
(Applaudissements)
Es Devlin : Avec U2, nous voyagions dans le public
sur un terrain couvrant trois décennies de politique, de poésie et de musique.
Après plusieurs mois à rencontrer le groupe et ses équipes créatives,
voici l'image qui revenait sans cesse,
celle d'une ligne, d'une rue,
la rue qui connecte le passé du groupe à son présent,
la corde raide sur laquelle ils ont marché en tant qu'activistes et artistes,
une virée à travers le cinéma
qui a permis au groupe de devenir acteur
de sa propre poésie.
(Musique : U2 « Là où les rues n'ont pas de noms »)
Bono : Je veux courir
Je veux me cacher
je veux démolir les murs
qui me retiennent prisonnier
Es Devlin: La fin du concert ressemble à la fin d'un vol.
C'est une arrivée.
C'est un transfert de la scène au public.
Pour le groupe britannique Take That,
on a envoyé, à la fin du concert, un androïde de 24 mètres de haut
en plein milieu de la foule.
(Musique)
Comme tant d'autres adaptations de la musique en mécanique,
on l'avait d'abord jugée totalement impossible sur le plan technique.
Les trois premiers ingénieurs consultés nous ont dit non,
et, finalement, nous avons réussi
en conservant toutes les pièces du système de contrôle ensemble
pendant qu'il parcourait le pays.
Il fallait le replier sur un camion à plateau
afin qu'il puisse voyager sans se désolidariser.
Et bien sûr, cela voulait dire que les dimensions de sa tête
étaient entièrement basées
par la hauteur du plus petit pont routier qu'il devait traverser pendant la tournée.
Et je dois avouer
qu'il y a un pont inévitable terriblement bas
juste à la sortie de Hambourg.
(Rires)
(Musique)
Un autre spectacle techniquement très complexe sur lequel nous avons travaillé
a été l'opéra de Carmen
au Festival de Bregenz, en Autriche.
Nous avions imaginé les mains de Carmen sortant du lac de Constance,
jetant son jeu de cartes en l'air,
cartes qui resteraient suspendues entre le ciel et le lac.
Mais ce geste éphémère, ce coup de poignet,
devait devenir une structure assez solide
pour tenir deux hivers autrichiens.
Il y a tellement de choses qu'on ne voit pas sur cette photo
et qui demandent un vrai travail.
Il y a beaucoup de lest, d'armature et d'appuis à l'arrière.
Je vais vous montrer les photos qui ne figurent pas en ligne.
Ce sont des photos de l'arrière du plateau,
la partie qui n'est pas conçue pour que le public la voie
quel que soit le travail requis.
Et c'est un vrai dilemme
pour un artiste qui crée des décors de scènes,
car la majeure partie de ce que je fais est faux,
c'est une illusion.
Et pourtant, tous les artistes cherchent à exprimer une vérité.
On se demande toujours :
« Peut-on exprimer la vérité en usant de mirages ? »
Quand j'assiste aux spectacles sur lesquels j'ai travaillé,
je me retrouve souvent à être la seule à ne pas regarder la scène.
Je regarde quelque chose que je trouve tout aussi fascinant,
c'est le public.
(Acclamations)
Dans quel autre endroit verriez-vous ceci :
tous ces humains, connectés, concentrés,
absorbés et rassemblés ?
Récemment, j'ai commencé un travail qui trouve sa source
dans la voix collective du public.
« Les Portraits d'un poème » est un poème collectif.
Il a commencé à la Galerie Serpentine de Londres,
tout le monde est invité à laisser un mot dans un poème collectif.
Et, au lieu de ce grand portrait LED
qui était diffusé au fond du stade,
chaque membre du public
peut emporter son portrait avec lui,
tissé avec les mots
qu'il a apportés au poème collectif.
Il garde ainsi un fragment d'une œuvre en perpétuelle évolution.
Et l'année prochaine, le poème collectif prendra une forme architecturale.
Voici le projet de pavillon britannique pour l'Exposition Universelle de 2020.
Le Royaume-Uni...
De mon vivant, on ne s'est jamais senti aussi divisé.
Les divisions n'ont jamais semblé aussi présentes.
Et il n'y jamais eu autant besoin de lieux
où se connecter et converger.
J'ai l'espoir que cette sculpture en bois,
cet instrument de bois, un peu comme ce violon dont je jouais,
soit un lieu où les gens peuvent jouer et proposer leurs mots
à l'une des extrémités du cône,
en émerger à l'autre extrémité
et constater que leur mot a rejoint un poème collectif, une voix commune.
(Musique)
Voici des expériences simples d'apprentissage automatique.
L'algorithme qui génère le poème collectif est assez simple.
C'est comme de l'écriture intuitive,
basée sur des millions de mots écrits par des poètes du 19ème siècle.
C'est donc une sorte de convergence d'intelligence, passée et présente,
organique et non organique.
Nous avons été inspirés par les mots de Stephen Hawking.
Vers la fin de sa vie, il se posait une question simple :
si, en tant qu'espèce, nous rencontrions une autre forme de vie évoluée,
une civilisation avancée
comment leur parlerions-nous ?
Quelle langue commune parlerions-nous en tant que planète ?
Le langage lumineux atteint tous les publics.
Nous en sommes tous touchés. Personne ne peut y résister.
Au théâtre, on commence chaque pièce dans un endroit sombre, sans lumière.
Nous restons debout toute la nuit, fixant la lumière, programmant la lumière,
essayant de trouver de nouvelles façons de tailler et sculpter la lumière.
(Musique)
Voici un portrait de nos pratiques,
toujours en quête de nouvelles façons de modeler et remodeler la lumière,
cherchant toujours des mots pour ce que nous n'avons plus besoin de dire.
Et je veux dire que ceci,
et tout ce que je viens de vous montrer,
n'existe plus sous forme physique.
(Musique)
En fait, beaucoup de mes réalisations de ces 25 dernières années
n'existent plus.
Mais notre travail perdure dans nos mémoires, dans des sculptures synaptiques,
dans les esprits de ceux qui étaient alors présents
dans le public.
(Musique)
J'ai lu, un jour, qu'un poème appris par cœur
est tout ce qu'il vous reste,
ce qui ne peut pas être perdu,
même si votre maison brûle et que vous perdez tous vos biens.
Je voudrais conclure avec quelques lignes apprises par cœur, il y a très longtemps.
(Musique)
Elles ont été écrites par le romancier anglais E. M. Forster,
en 1910, quelques années avant que l'Europe, mon continent,
(Musique)
ne commence à se déchirer.
Et son appel à l'unité résonne encore
dans la plupart des choses que nous faisons maintenant.
(Musique)
« Il suffit de mettre en communication ! En cela tenait tout son sermon.
Il suffit de mettre en communication la prose et la passion,
et toutes deux s’élèveront.
On contemplera l’amour humain à sa hauteur.
Il suffit de mettre en communication ! Pour ne plus vivre en fragments. »
Merci.
(Applaudissements)